in the wake of the police killing of
George Floyd in Minneapolis protests
have erupted around the country some of
these have turned violent and resulted
in injuries to citizens and police as
well as looting and other forms of
property damage cities have implemented
curfews and other restrictions on
movement further stoking tensions due to
the coronavirus lockdown the start of
summer and a 15 percent unemployment
rate the last time the nation faced this
level of social unrest was 1968 the year
that Martin Luther King and Robert F
Kennedy were assassinated to help us
make sense of the current moment and
figure out where it could lead
I spoke with Princeton University
political scientist Omar Rosso who has
studied how protests of the 1960's
affected public opinion social discourse
and voting patterns will today's
protests make policing reform more or
less likely is it possible that violence
in the streets will boost donald trump's
reelection chances just as events in
1968 helped put Richard Nixon in the
White House huasos research also looks
at the nature of police misconduct
analyzing whether headline-grabbing
incidents such as the horrific killings
of Eric garner and Tamir rice are the
result of a few bad apples or a systemic
problem with law enforcement in minority
communities
I spoke with WASO who is currently in
Los Angeles via zoom oh thanks for
talking to Reason thank you for having
me
can you outline your findings about
protests violence and political disc
political outcomes sure so the big
picture is that a lot of research
suggested that protests should have
little to no effect in politics bunch of
people go out on the street they make
some noise you know it doesn't matter
elites dominate politics and what I
found consistent with some other
research on protests is that in fact
protests are influential and my work in
particular finds that protests are
influential through the effect they have
on media
and so protests shape what the media
talked about and what the media talked
about in turn influences public opinion
and that then shapes why people in
Congress are doing or what kind of
legislation gets passed or in fact as
you mentioned who might win a presidency
lends good you know presidential
election
in you know I read her down the road and
obviously this is wild speculation of
the type that academics never want to
indulge in but I'm gonna force you to
but you you were looking at the period
between 1960 to 1972 and before we get
into what you fam there do it is there a
difference in the way media you know
media back then is very different than
media now do you would worry at all
about the relevance of your research not
for explaining what happened of what
might be going on now it's a really good
question and I think there are some
really important differences and also
some important similarities so why don't
I go through some of the differences
first so clearly there are way more
media now than there were in the past
and not just that but it's much more
fragmented right so every one of us has
our own distinct social media feed that
is going to be unique and give us a
different vantage point on the same
event let alone hundreds events around
the country we also have a kind of
intimacy that comes from people's
cellphone footage and so where the power
of a single image in the 1960s that was
conveyed on a newspaper
might have brought you there to a degree
I still don't think that's as powerful
as sitting watching George Floyd be
killed before your own eyes I mean the
sort of the anger and rage and grief
that that triggers when you see a man
crying for his mother as he as you know
as a cop has his knee and his neck like
like that's a kind of visceral intimate
powerful terrifying direct experience of
media that that was only partly conveyed
in the past right because even even when
we were able to see very stark images
dogs being set loose on protesters and
things like that oftentimes it was
either a still image or
or we didn't see it at all because the
networks weren't really showing that
kind of brutality yeah I mean one just
given that we have a little bit of extra
time to kind of go into some of these
details one of the remarkable things
about Bloody Sunday is that there is a
national documentary about the Nuremberg
trials that's playing on television and
they cut into a you know sort of a story
about Nazi war crimes to footage in
Selma of people like representative John
Lewis being beaten brutally by police
and vigilantes and so that contrast in
that moment was exceedingly powerful and
there's good evidence that it really did
shock the conscience of the nation and
and and and and for a lot of people made
them realize that you know what's going
on in the south is not normal politics
this is unacceptable and I think they're
so so there are moments that are in the
past that are that visceral but I think
what's what's different now is the way
in which there are things that black
people have been saying for a long time
police engage in abusive behavior in our
communities and now people can see it
for themselves in a way that really
maybe began with video of the beating of
Rodney King but has become much more a
part of our common lived experience and
I suspect has played a role in making
particularly white liberals more attuned
to black concerns about racial equality
one similarity though I think between
the 1960s and now is that the media tend
to rely on some fairly common scripts or
narratives for how stories get told and
one of those is a kind of a right script
or a you know kind of a justice
narrative and another is more of a crime
script and what we're seeing what we saw
in the 60s was that nonviolent protests
particularly nonviolent protests met
with state repression with vigilante
violence were much more likely to be
presented as a kind of redress of
grievances as a demonstration as a march
as a call for civil rights
so nonviolent protests today produced a
headline about civil rights tomorrow
whereas when protesters engaged in
violence that predicted a headline about
riots tomorrow
that was much more likely to focus on
crime and disorder and public opinion
moves very closely with that so when the
newspapers are talking about civil
rights civil rights becomes the most
important problem in public opinion
surveys and when newspapers are heavily
covering crime and riots crime and riots
become the thing that is the most
important problem and so the tactics
that are employed by protesters can
really make a powerful impact on how the
media tell the story which in turn
shapes public opinion and I think that's
still likely to be quite true today in
the in the sixties and especially coming
out of the civil rights movement it
seems as if and this might be an
artifact both of my not understanding it
fully but also looking backwards that
civil rights marches were were kind of
scripted they were organized that people
who participated in them were taught
passive resistance and kind of like
don't fight back etc today's protests
all over the country seem to be much
less organized does that factor into
this at all or you know did did the I
guess in a way did the 60s protesters
know what they were doing in a way that
it doesn't necessarily seem clear that
what's going on today is under anybody's
control I think that's right that
there's a I mean a lot of the protests
in the 60s that escalated to violence
started out as organized nonviolent
civil disobedience but when people are
you know enraged about you know a police
killing or some aspect of state violence
it's just it can be very hard to sustain
that level of kind of order and focus
particularly if the nonviolent protest
which were successful in part employed
producing lots and lots of images of
state violence of police killings and so
once people are kind of seeing that
imagery and getting angry it becomes
much harder to kind of I think to do
that very discipline you know as you
said passive resistance and took
training that takes incredible you know
perseverance to sort of let somebody hit
you and not hit back but the
another dimension to what you're saying
which is I think even more true today
which is that the part of what's
powerful about cell phones and you know
the internet and music a variety of
communications technologies is it makes
the transaction costs for coordinating a
large-scale gathering much much lower
than they would have been in the 60s and
so it's now possible for you know
somebody buy a Twitter or Facebook to
kind of say we're meeting at this
location and that solves the
coordination problem and suddenly in a
very spontaneous and not coordinated in
the you know we train we we've been
getting into sort of way that makes it
possible for there to be this kind of
explosion of activity that lacks a
center and any kind of kind of coherent
agenda or organizer now of course there
are organizers involved in these events
and their organizers who have a long
history doing work but but they're just
sort of one constituency in in this you
know have explosion of activity and to
be clear most of these protests have
been peaceful but but but there are many
constituencies and and and and and
you're exactly right it's it's much less
centrally organized one of the you know
I I want to say I'm I was gonna say
weird that is quite right one of the
kind of disturbing discoveries of your
research is really that the best
outcomes from a kind of civil rights
perspective were when protesters were
nonviolent and the state police law
enforcement were violent is that
accurate
and why did that why do you think that
helps push civil rights forward yeah
that that's a good summary and and let
me step back and sort of set up one part
of why that the logic of that and so
initially nonviolent protesters in the
south were getting attention but as one
reporter said of a very large protest in
Hattiesburg Mississippi
if there's you know no conflict if
there's no violence this is this is a
boring store
you know what what I want is blood and
guts that's what makes a story and what
the leaders of the nonviolent civil
rights movement figured out was that
what what really generated national
press was when there was state
repression that was you know excessive
and that partly was useful because it
got the presses attention and generated
national media it also was really
important because a lot of white
moderates
who might have you know had some
awareness of a sense of you know racial
you know that Jim Crow was this kind of
that black for second-class citizens in
the south but it didn't they didn't
really didn't move them politically they
could view a nonviolent protest as
something that was normal politics look
the systems working only when there was
an excess of state repression when there
was this kind of brutal you know as you
mentioned sticking dogs on on young
people the fire hoses on young people in
that context it's very hard for the kind
of disengage or maybe even hostile white
moderate outside the country to say hey
it's working okay the system is you know
it's normal politics so so the strategic
use of violence where protesters were
the object of violence both shock the
conscience of the country into saying
okay wait that's that's that's a little
beyond what we were comfortable with and
got the media to become you know very
engaged what was the role you know and
I'm thinking of Martin Luther King's
letter from Birmingham jail where you
know that's addressed the white moderate
so we're saying you know you gotta wait
you gotta wait the system is working and
he gestures towards if you if you don't
deal with me with you know with a
peaceful person who's willing to work
through the system but it's going to
push the issue you're gonna have to deal
with violent elements in in the kind of
black civil rights movements Black
Panthers or the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Council of Committee is is
that kind of dynamic at play here do you
think because you know is there is there
a sense that we as a country we need to
deal
just peacefully otherwise there is a set
of grips whether it's an Tifa or
something else that's gonna cause many
more problems yeah so I think the that
sometimes called like a radical flank
hypothesis the idea is if there's a kind
of a threatening more extreme group that
makes the the moderates more attractive
to negotiate with and I think broadly
that's plausible and I don't think
there's any reason to doubt that kind of
those dynamics are at play in any kind
of negotiation in the early part of the
1960's certainly Malcolm X is a presence
but Black Power movement the Black
Panthers haven't really come onto the
scene when the 1964 Civil Rights Act was
passed when the 65 Voting Rights Act was
passed and the big wave of violent
protest activity comes after 65 right so
really the the biggest high-profile
violent protest is in watts and that
comes just after the Voting Rights Act
so so I think it's very reasonable to
say that in fact the threat of violent
resistance while certainly always a part
of I think white leaders consciousness
is is not the thing that's driving the
passage of the Voting Rights Act or the
Civil Rights Act I think it's much but
what I look when I see in my public
opinion data is the more people who are
engaging in nonviolent protest the more
public opinion changes and both with the
Civil Rights Act and the Voting Rights
Act within a year those laws get enacted
and so moving public opinion growing the
coalition of people in favor of those
changes move politics in the later
period there is some evidence that
violence did in fact produce certain
kinds of benefits for black communities
but I also find in addition to those
benefits that violence probably
contributed to a growing of the
law-and-order
coalition that that really was pushing
for more repressive policies to yeah can
you talk a bit about 1968 in in the
article that you wrote that comes up and
you basically say that
because of violent behavior by
protesters or fear of that by white
voters they tipped into the Republican
camp Richard it's it's kind of hard to
you know I I guess recovered this
history at least in a public in a common
sense but Nixon it was a three-way race
with Nixon Humphrey and George Wallace
who was an explicit segregationist Nixon
got in with a very poor ality about it's
not a majority by any stretch how did
you know what were the events that made
people made white scared that they ended
up going into the Republican camp and
letting mix and eke out of that trip
yeah so I think just to put this you
framed it all really well and I just
wanted to take one step even further
back and say let's start with Goldwater
who ran on law and order and lost and
lost badly and so there's a puzzle from
that sort of was one of the things that
motivated my research which really
begins with where did law in order come
from how did mass incarceration become
you know what is it about what happened
in the late 60s and 70s that kind of
seemed to lay the groundwork for this
hockey-stick increase in incarceration
in this country and the puzzle is why
did law and order fail for Goldwater but
work for Nixon and and there's even one
more dimension to that Ronald Reagan
runs on law and order for the
governorship of California in 1966 and
so and he wins substantially and so so
Glen order isn't working in 64 it is
working in 66 it is working in 68 and if
can I complicate or throw in another log
on the fire here kind of which is that
Nixon did pretty well among
african-americans in 1960 when he was
running against Kennedy I mean he was
what to get like 25-30 percent or
something like that I mean it was
substantially higher than any any
Republican has gotten since yeah well so
that's a really important point and let
me go and try to braid it together with
with kind of two ideas right so one is
that you know why does Reagan beat the
incumbent Pat Brown who
been quite popular there's evidence in
my research and others that there's a
strong shift among a certain subset of
Democrats away from the Democratic Party
following the Watts uprising in 1965
all right so law and order becomes a
winning strategy following watts and
then in 67 and 68 they're very large
violent protests and to be clear while
what we're seeing now is quite dramatic
compared to what was happening in the
60s these are still relatively modest
events I don't want to minimize any any
particular injury death you know
building going up in flames but in watts
there was something like 3,000 incidents
of arson so just a totally different
scale of unrest and the and so that sort
of pushes these issues you know and
again the media is covering this there's
this very dramatic footage and that
means that what we see in public opinion
is that socially that issues of crime
and riots are moving up in the summer
down in the winter up in the summer down
in the winter as we build up to 1968 and
so the public opinion data looks very
consistent with the story about the
public is responding to what's happening
on the ground that violent protest is
driving a concern about crime and riots
are the most important problem in
America and the other issue that you
brought up which is a really important
one is basically in 1964 the Democrats
you know this in 1960 it's not clear
which party is the party of
african-american interest the the the
the Republican Party is actually more
liberal than the Democratic Party on a
civil rights bill that's that's
introduced before 64 but basically with
64 with Johnson kind of leading the
charge on the party side and the
pressure from activists with things like
the march on Washington in 63 the
Democrats become the party of civil
rights we the Democrats split from the
southern Democratic wing which was
segregationist and becomes the party
aligned with African American interests
and in that shift suddenly Nixon who
might have been more progressive on race
has a you know there's a kind of
realignment of the parties where one is
the party of black
interests and one is the party
essentially over time becomes the party
of a certain class of white interests
and that means that law and order which
is not explicitly racial but but it's
kind of coded language that translates
as you know I'm gonna keep those out
groups in control and so the combination
of the Civil Rights Act and the you know
unrest on the ground sort of produces
this competition over race in our party
system and the Democratic Party is you
know it doesn't have the Republicans
were the only issue of law and order
then for the next fifty or sixty years
you know kind of flash forwarding to
contemporary America Donald Trump in
ran as a law and order candidate I mean
he used that phrase arcing back at least
to the Nixon in the in the current
context I mean it seems like Trump is
very much
you know he's anti protests Eddie
equates any kind of protest with rioting
and that type of thing does that mean
you know and then you have Joe Biden who
weirdly you know it's been part of the
American political establishment for
fifty years played big roles and things
like ramping up the drug war crime bills
that put a lot of black people in
particular in jail he's walked back some
of his legend what used to be his
legislative accomplishments is there a
clear you know like is there a clear
sense of where any of this goes in the
2020 election yeah that's a really
important question I think there are a
couple of things that are predictable
and a bunch of things that are super
unpredictable and in the kind of
predictable scenario right we know we've
just seen Trump will almost always play
to his base and has very little interest
in trying to you know bridge divides his
his just first instinct consistently is
to kind of turn up the volume on
division and we're seeing that right now
and although it's also bizarre in a way
that he did better with African
Americans and Latinos than either Mitt
Romney or or John McCain so it you know
I mean he's still below double digits
but yeah I mean it he might have done
nine percent with like seven yeah and I
think to be clear there's a certain kind
of in particular man who appreciates a
kind of macho candidate and has a lot of
Appeal these sort of there's some
evidence that we've seen a kind of
sorting of the parties on a taste for
what in political science is called the
authoritarianism but you think of as you
know a more traditional social order
more patriarchal more you know there's
there's a black-and-white view of the
world and so if you're an African
American who has those kind of
authoritarian tendencies Trump may be
very appealing yeah but that's still a
very small percentage right overall but
you're right it's a higher number among
Latinos and I think the big picture
though is that Trump is you know has it
has already run on law and order it
depending on how the next few weeks and
some are play out it may or may not
continue to be really salient come
November but if it does it's almost
certain that that's going to be a core
part of his message because his entire
campaign going back to his first address
was you know there are these criminal
elements you know maybe they're Mexican
but later they're you know blacks and
cities and I'm I alone can fix it right
and so he's the he's the strong man and
so I think that's you know that's a
fairly it doesn't think a lot of
research to say that's a conservative
you know safe pretty good um but what I
think is unpredictable is he's the
incumbent and in some cases it might
mean that he is associated with the
disorder and and so there there may be
people who you know like some of what he
has to offer but feel like he's actually
more of a Kaos agent than a source of
stability and the key thing that I see
in my research that I think is still at
play today is in the earlier era
and I think this is hard for people to
really wrap their heads around there are
people who are open to racial equality
right like Johnson wins in a landslide
in 1964 and there's a lot going on there
there's Kennedy's assassination but the
civil rights bill has passed and there's
a democratic coalition of white
moderates and white liberals and African
Americans that holds right so this it's
not just the 64 Civil Rights Act that
splinters the Democratic coalition and I
think that there's
so the key idea is there are white
moderates who are you know they don't
prioritize racial equality but they're
not opposed to it necessarily but they
do care about order and so they're kind
of adjudicating between a party that
they might like some things about and
has racial equality as a core plank and
a party that says I'm gonna really fight
for order and those white moderates can
really play a critical role in tipping
an election I find that that you know
it's mid-atlantic states and Midwestern
states that are the ones that
potentially tip in 1968 that's quite
similar to what happened in 2016 where
the states in play you know or Wisconsin
in Ohio and Michigan and so I think it's
likely that in 2020
even though whites on average are much
more concerned about racial equality
that they're going to be these swing
voters who you know our sympathetic to
bloc concerns and care about order and
are going to be pulled between Biden and
Trump and the kinds of narratives that
come out of these protest movements the
kind of narratives that come from the
two candidates are really gonna help
those folks align with one camp or
another and I and I don't know quite how
that's going to play out yeah it's
interesting to realize - you know the
first big explosion of this round of
protests come out of Minneapolis which
is a Midwestern state but and reliably
democratic and kind of liberal but then
also kind of Midwestern conservative
places like Louisville Kentucky which is
kind of the south but not really really
heartland can I ask this is a kind of
orthogonal I guess this question of you
know when we look at nine
1868 versus now in in I would say and
and correct if you disagree with this
you know in most ways the country is
unrecognizable in terms of race
relations in terms of equality not just
for african-americans but from women
sexual orientation is is not an issue it
was unspeakable in 1968 it's less and
less of an issue if it's one at all
today how do we talk about progress
along racial lines that is incomplete or
is still problematic because one of the
things that was kind of remarkable about
this the event with George Floyd or the
killing of him even versus Ferguson is
that nobody was really defending the
police actions here nobody I you know
you really searched even people like
Trump are not saying that he deserved to
die or he caused his death
everybody's saying this is wrong how do
we account for that without you know
saying okay so we really don't have to
do more so it's a really good question
and I think the way I think about this
is a kind of Tale of Two Cities story
that following the you know especially
the breaking of Jim Crow a really
remarkable act of insurgency by
african-americans to overturn an
oppressive regime following that that
movement we'd have both enormous
progress for african-americans in
particular and for call it the bottom
you know 40 percent of African Americans
really a terrible in some cases even
worse situation and so it's it's it's we
have to be able to hold that kind of
dual path at the same time and so on the
progress side you know you've got an
enormous opening up of opportunity
educational employment housing I mean
just a real flourishing of the black
middle class in a way that is really
important to recognize and to appreciate
and reflects absolutely progress in
America and at the same time and this is
part of what took me back to school
you know and when we're talking about
issues of mass incarceration and
criminal justice right we have the rise
of the war on drugs we have this massive
hockey stick increase in incarceration
and all sorts of other kinds of really
devastating social and economic effects
in the black community in particular so
you know employment opportunities as
part of deindustrialization become much
tougher and there any number of other
sorts of you know sort of kinds of
social dislocation that are happening
particularly for that bottom forty
percent and I think part of what is so
important about what happened with
George Floyd and to be clear again
exactly as you said it the police
killing of George Floyd is that it
really focuses our attention on one of
the core issues that has been a source
of trauma over the last half-century
which is that criminal justice has been
just a profoundly unequal and a
profoundly you know brutal system for
african-americans and that that is
affecting the bottom forty percent much
more than for african-americans the top
fifty president I'm not saying that
there aren't lots of folks you know my
former advisor Henry Louis Gates getting
you know arrested in his own home you
know that I'm not saying those things
don't happen but it's but it's it's way
more devastating for the people who get
kind of trapped in a criminal justice
system that just does not let people go
and kind of arrange all of their life
chances and so that's how I think of the
the you know it has there been progress
enormous progress particularly on the
things they're talking about the kind of
social liberalism stuff but but and a
bunch of material well-being and in
particular in kind of terms of Liberty
right the number of people who are
locked in cages we have not made
progress right and I you know that was
part of I think what came out of the you
know the Ferguson moment there of
recognizing how how many levels of kind
of social control through fines and and
other types of police and which
definitely just you know
disproportionately affected
and screwed over black communities there
was that was invisible to a lot of
people yeah that's right and and and and
and so that there was a kind of
essentially taxation through fees so you
know that the state was funding its
activities by you know petty fines that
would accrue and could be devastating I
mean I just think when I was reading
about that that moment I was thinking
about a ticket I got for speeding and I
was going the same speed as everybody
else I got you know at the end of the
month it was clear they had a quota I
got picked and I was so angry I didn't
pay it for you know another whatever it
was I missed the deadline two times and
I just I was screwing myself over but I
was so angry about the fee and the
feeling of you know this this wrongful
kind of ticket that you know my way of
protesting was in some ways to screw
myself over by not paying but you could
pay it I mean and then it that's the
type of thing where it'd be you know it
becomes a never-ending sinkhole for
people who don't have the who can't pay
that's right and I I'm coming to that
with great privilege so III ultimately
paid it and my life is fine right but
imagine if you couldn't pay it or
imagine there's this kind of like you
know devastating the cruel of all sorts
of you know your grass isn't cut at the
right height kind of stuff that can be
really maddening and then you throw into
that and unjust what like what people
perceive to be an unjust killing and
it's just it's you know it's a kind of
tinder and you're right that that's
that's that was invisible and and I
think it's important on this on the
progress side to note that as much as
people might think the black lives
matter movement kind of petered out as
Trump gained power or came into office
we've seen at the local level Reform
DA's in cities across the country win
there have been changes and use of force
policies that have had material benefits
for you know reducing the amount of
police abuse that we observe and so I
think that's also less visible but there
really has been a reform movement that
has made progress and I suspect that
even Trump is kind of operating in some
ways in a new set of constraints where
he might you know say blue lives matter
black lives matter but he doesn't want
to align himself with the guy who you
know kills a man crying for his mother
on camera yet in fact I mean he signed
the first-step Act he's done he's made
certain gestures towards criminal
justice reform which are actually
historic so you know and when you go
back to like at the more local or state
level certain types of asset forfeiture
laws have been changed and cash bail is
being repealed in places which are all
you know very positive developments
let's talk a little bit about policing a
reform of policing because that is kind
of front and center there you know one
of the things that have you know some of
the protests and I I'm in New York City
I was along a protest yesterday that
very quickly went from talking about
George Floyd in other recent cases of
violent death at the hands of law
enforcement to you know attacking
capitalism writ large and all sorts of
other types of things but to go back to
this this you know primary issue of
police reform you've you've written on
Twitter you or you've talked about how
people when they talk about reform they
tend to either say we need like a
complete system at reform or we just
need to pull the bad apples out and you
and you've stressed that in fact you
know it's it's both and that you know
getting rid of bad apples is it
recognizing who the bad players are in a
system is a lot easier than we seem to
believe could you talk a little bit
about what what's going on there and
what your analysis shows yeah this was
really striking to me when I started
looking into this a few years ago so you
know the bad apples rhetoric says you
know most cops are okay we just have
some rogue actors right and the system
system story says you know the whole
thing is corrupt and you kind of need
all cops are bad and what was sort of
surprising to me when I looked at some
of the data is how disproportionate it
is in terms of
a very small percentage of cops generate
a way disproportionate percentage of the
civilian complaints so in a place like
Chicago it was something like 1% of cops
generate 25 percent of the civilian
complaints in New York there were cops
who had you know 20 30 50 civilian
complaints who were still out on the
street and if you look at the pattern
the the cop who shoots laQuan McDonald
in Chicago had something like 17
complaints against him the guy who
chokeholds Eric garner and you know as
he's screaming I can't breathe had I
think it was like 12 complaints against
him there are pens oh and and and the
person who killed George Floyd had a
pattern of abuse rug and so if you are
thinking about this you know the bad
apples versus systems question what
became very clear to me is in fact the
modal police officer you know that I
think in New York I'm something like 40%
had zero complaints against them right
so so in fact there are a lot of cops
and I'm you know whether you are pro or
anti copper that's even the wrong frame
like it's clear that there are some cops
who are doing way more harm than others
and getting those cops off the street
would do a lot of good right Eric garner
if you live on what are what are the
obstacles what you know what are the
obstacles to you know when you you know
when you have such a small percentage of
cops causing so many of the complaints
you know what are what are the obstacles
to pulling them out of the system yeah
well I mean I think this this speaks to
the need to kind of focus on both
systems and individuals right and that
clearly there's a systemic failure which
is the you know like these cops engaged
in repeated abuse aren't being
sanctioned in any sufficient way fired
you know put on a desk job demoted in
some way that sends a signal to everyone
else you know that's out of that's off
bounds right um and so that's the
systemic part of the failure is that
like is that is that a union thing is
that a solid area like a thin blue line
type of thing or what's causing that
Isis so I think part of what's
remarkable of this issue is it is
actually terrible for cops right
having a cop who needs a man to death on
his neck is terrible for cops and if you
were you know a kind of rational police
union you would be interested in getting
the rogue actors out of our you know you
know out of your profession and I think
in a lot of contexts there's it's a thin
blue line it's a kind of you know a
level of solidarity that defends almost
every kind of action by police and and
in fact if the police unions if the
police you know kind of you know I mean
the mayors and and and governors who
oversee these institutions if they were
much tougher on that 1 to 2 percent we
could potentially be reducing the level
of abuse you know 25 percent right and
that really matters um another example
of this that's kind of you know getting
that that that worst officer out Tamir
rice right child playing with a toy gun
shot by a cop who had been fired by
another police station police force
because he was deemed as unfit and then
hired by the force that ultimately in
which he he shot Tamir rice right and so
so so again and again the people
engaging in these kind of egregious
abuse have this pattern and the other
thing I think could be coming back your
question about how why doesn't it change
I think in some ways focusing on the
system change is really hard that's like
a big kind of pot to boil and part of
what I was arguing in one piece I wrote
for the route is that it's you know part
of what you want as a movement is cases
that put the opposition on their heels
right and so a cop in New York who has
51 complaints against him that's really
hard to defend and that's that's a
really good place to be if you're trying
to push for reform and accountability
for police and so my argument was partly
there's a material benefit right you
might have fewer of these kinds of
abuses but it's also rhetorically very
powerful to focus on these extreme cases
that while maybe only 1% still matter
enormous ly in terms of the quality of
life for black communities you know
final question how
how do you feel you know about the you
know the next three four five six months
this is you know we have the kovat
lockdown we have massive unemployment we
have you know hot weather warm weather
good weather coming out you know and now
like you know one of the most intense
convulsions of you know of a number of
overlapping issues you know that are
that are causing real disruption and
ferment you know what are you thinking
you know are we gonna get through this
or is there gonna is gonna get a lot
worse so let me enter in in kind of a
couple of parts so so I think the
pessimistic part of me says I don't have
much optimism that there's going to be
any kind of rapid change on criminal
justice issues I think that's a long
slow fight that for which there is real
progress you know decriminalization of
marijuana you know these das getting
elected there is real progress on
criminal justice issues but the
apparatus is so vast that it's going to
take a long time to try and make headway
on that and so I fear for our country
and as much as there will be more of
these horrible police killing of unarmed
black people caught on camera for years
to come and that's that's that's a
terrible thing and I wish I had more
optimism about that but on a more
encouraging note I think in the sixties
there was a sense of the whole social
fabric was coming undone and so we had
Martin Luther King assassinated two
Kennedys assassinated the the world was
just you know there's a level of social
unrest yes what happened this past
weekend was dramatic but again in the
60s you're talking about you know
thousands of instance of our arson in a
place like Detroit the National Guard
comes in shoots 15,000 rounds of
ammunition 34 people die I mean it's
it's it's it's a level of like low-grade
civil unrest that looks like a civil war
or something kind of akin to that and
this is not at all at that level at
least at this stage and so I I also feel
like
there's some reason to think that we're
moving through this in a way that's
that's that's likely to not kind of tear
the fabric entirely but I think the
really big question that's not
specifically about Trump or the unrest
is that our kind of our democratic
institutions are in some ways being
challenged and so you know can we
maintain a kind of core commitment to
both things like you know civil rights
and civil liberties and voting and
voting rights and I worry about
democratic erosion in this country so I
tried to find the optimistic note it was
not it but I guess I guess it's more
peaceful period and I think that that
stability is good for you know for
progress well it's it's odd because you
know when Trump gave his inaugural
speech where he was talking about
American carnage and he was describing
an America you know that was bleeding
you know from street crime that maybe
existed in the 70s but certainly wasn't
anything common and but by the same
token when you go back to the late 60s
the level the amounts of trust and
confidence in the government and other
institutions and authority was much much
higher than it is now so it's kind of
you know where you know there's much
less crime but there's also much less
confidence yeah I don't know where that
leads well I think you know we are at
the frontier of a challenge that I don't
think it's been fully appreciated is
that and that goes back to your point
about you know between 60 and 64 what
changes we're trying to build a
multiracial democracy and that turns out
to be an exceedingly difficult thing and
that a bunch of countries that have
multi-ethnic states converge to not
really being democracies they they kind
of become ethno nationalists
authoritarian States there are examples
like Canada that kind of embrace being
multi-ethnic States or I mean I think
we're in the middle of this convulsion
we're part of Trump's appeal is he
saying no no I'm gonna reassert the old
social order right make America great
again with whites and Christians on
and and and there's a kind of counter
mobilization which to be clear you know
Trump didn't get a majority of the vote
and young people have not much love for
Trump and so so I think that the
transition that we're in the middle of
is is is bumpy one reason to think that
there may be a large constituency in the
future for a peaceful free multi-ethnic
democracy is in fact in the social
unrest is a call for enough of the state
violence right it's not a call for you
know crush the ethnic minority yes and
and so so I have some confidence that
we're moving in the right direction in
terms of building this kind of
prosperous peaceful multi-ethnic society
but there's still a lot of inequality
and a lot of of state violence against
in particular black and Latino people
and so so you know the point is in that
transition things are really bumpy and I
think we're in the transition now but I
also have some optimism that we're
moving towards a period where the ethno
nationalist contingent no longer has a
winning national coalition you know can
I you know you you came into my view or
I first learned about you through both
my predecessor a breeze in Virginia
posture but through your website black
planet you were part of you I struck me
as and you were on places like MSNBC if
I'm not mistaken but you were kind of an
avatar of a of a tech a techno utopian
or techno optimist moment where one
thing that was kind of fantastic about
the late 90s and I realized part of this
is just old man ism on my part but that
we had gotten to a point where we could
be more individualized in every aspect
of our lives you know in our commercial
lives and you know how we could order
things how we can monogram things but
also on our on our identities I mean on
the most date you know the most
meaningful expressions of ourselves
that we were no longer just seeing each
other in terms of black and white or
male or female or East Coast West Coast
whatever everything became much more
nuanced and complicated in a good way
did that you know like I mean that isn't
how we're talking anymore we're talking
in the most kind of brute terms of
ethnic identity or tribal you know
tribalism whether it's racial ethnic or
political is there any way back to that
earlier kind of glimpse of a different
future that was not scornful of identity
but rather you know it was like let's
instead of being one of two things let's
be one of tenors you know ten or twenty
six yeah so I think the you know you for
jigna posture l once said to me that
nature abhors a void as it relates to
politics and so she was always skeptical
of the metamour anarchists schools of
thought because to her mind into that
void was going to come some you know
more probably authoritarian power and we
might think about something similar with
identity where people have a deep need
to feel kind of rooted in community and
and in a sense of you know people hood
and that doesn't mean it's not mutually
exclusive with what you said about I can
be you know black and into anime and you
know somebody who likes to you know I
don't know ride a motorcycle but but I
think there's just a profoundly human
need for connection and those
connections often have a kind of you
know their their the rooted in in in
history of groups that we can ascribe
meaning to and and I say all of that to
say that like I you come to California
where I am right now and I remember
talking to a friend of mine who teaches
at a high school here and we were you
know at school is 90% Latino and so in a
school that's 90% Latino there are
Latino Goths and Latino skate punks and
Patito you know rockers and that's like
yeah the heterogeneity heterogeneity is
there
but it's not uncoupled from them also
feeling very rooted in you know like the
Mexican American community in LA or
something and it so I think it's
possible for both to exist but it's also
required something like California where
some of those cleavages aren't the
organizing cleavages by which kind of
power operates right and right now if
you're you know if you feel like you're
being over-policed as an
african-american and it's sort of your
you're out your side hobbies aren't
gonna be the thing you mobilize around
and conversely if you are you know a
white evangelical Christian who says I
am angry about you know transgender
bathrooms and same-sex marriage and the
you know me too and and black lives
matter you feel like you're you know
values are under assault and it becomes
important to you to kind of mobilize
with the people who share those values
to to try and assert you know your power
and so I think we're in a bit of a shake
out where those axes really matter in
terms of who has power and how laws get
made but but but they also might fade to
agree with time I think the the slightly
more concerning version of it is
research that suggests we are moving
into a world where essentially party
becomes the overarching identity yeah
and and that might mean that in fact
going back to Virginia's idea about you
know nature abhors a void and we clearly
not her phrase but but I was talking to
her that it may be that there isn't
actually a kind of more atomic state for
humans that were always going to be
tending towards an agglomeration and
that you know quirky editors who have a
rebellious peak you know you're in what
I think of the Groucho Marx club like
you would not join any club that would
have you as a member but that's not
doing yeah the idea that you know the
limit of my identity is going to be
either Republican
mccr attic it's God you know that's very
depressing and I hate to end on that
note but Omar was--and I want we'll
leave it here thanks so much Princeton
University political scientists you can
find contact information and what sex
feels for this interview Omar thank you
so much for talking Thank You Nick
really appreciate it